Democrats are confused why President
Trump's foreign policy seems to be
working the media experts demonstrate
they know nothing about gender or babies
and we checked the mailbag i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
so time coming up on today's show plus
I'm gonna tell you a little bit later in
the show who our special guest is for
our Sunday special it's somebody that
you know somebody that I think that you
will like our lineup is really good
we've been starting to reach out to a
lot of folks for the Sunday special and
the guests that we're having a really
first-rate but before I get to any of
today's news first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Birch gold so
bird school is the place to go if you
are interested in diversifying a little
bit of your portfolio obviously the
stock market is doing really well the
dollar is quite strong right now all of
that is wonderful but things change and
this is why you should hedge your bets
at least a little bit and have some of
your money in precious metals that's
what Birch gold can do for you they are
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases and right now thanks for a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
they have a long-standing track record
of continued success with thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau ask all of your
questions to my friends over at Birch
gold group and when you call them up
right now when you contact them and get
a free information kit on physical
precious metals this comprehensive 16
page kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings hey can legally
move that IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds into a precious metals and
precious metals IRA to get that no cost
no obligation kit right now go to
birchgold.com slash been birchgold.com /
been if you are interested in hedging
your bets if you're interested in
hedging against inflation or the
possibility of corruption in the
government or just volatility generally
it's not a bad idea to have at least a
little bit of your money in precious
metals birchgold.com / menus that slash
pen so they know that we sell you okay
so president romans had a very good week
on foreign policy a very good week on
foreign policy first of all there was
the removal of the United States from
the Iran deal which was as I have said
many times a very strong move a useful
move also president Trump was able to
bring home three American citizens who
had been held captive in North Korea
they thanked him for it all of this very
good for president Trump and Democrats
are sort of baffled by all of this they
don't understand why is it that Donald
Trump this rube the supposed itty --it
why is it that his foreign policy seems
to be achieving greater results than
Barack Obama's awful foreign policy
which was based very much on the idea of
a world working together where we reach
out our hands in
open-hand and we never threaten no we
never threaten if we do threaten we
don't really mean it like in Syria but
instead what we really should do is we
should all just hug it out why is it
that Donald Trump's view is working
better and why does it resonate more
with Americans why is it you can see the
puzzlement on the faces of the folks in
the media they just cannot understand
why it is the Donald Trump seems to be
succeeding in this way the latest
indicator comes courtesy of NBC's Hallie
Jackson so Haley Jackson was covering
president Trump's photo-op with the with
the Koreans who with the American
citizens in North Korea who had been
released and Trump went to meet them on
the tarmac at like 2:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m.
and then he spoke about it and watch
NBC's coverage here because it truly is
amazing when you juxtapose this coverage
with the coverage of the media at Bowe
Bergdahl's
released back to the United States by
Isis you recall that Bowe Bergdahl had
been taken prisoner rather by al-qaeda
and you recall that the presidents of
the United States traded five top
terrorists for Bowe Bergdahl who was in
fact a traitor it turns out that that he
was being tried for desertion and Bowe
Bergdahl this was treated as a wonderful
thing you know Barack Obama have photo
op in the Rose Garden with Bowe
Bergdahl's parents talking about how
wonderful it was to bring Bowe Bergdahl
home this American hero bringing him
home Obama didn't call me hero other
members of his administration did and
the media covered this straight and the
cover look at look at what Barack Obama
did that's just so magnificent and so
wonderful what there's no question that
these particular American citizens were
not in fact deserters from the American
military we didn't have to trade
terrorists to get the meth but watch
NBC's coverage Haley Jackson but what
was striking was that this was was a
Donald Trump's a former reality show
producer this was a staged production
meant for television meant for the
cameras meant to be shown and seen here
in this country and around the world you
had floodlights lighting up this 30 by
50 foot American flag hanging in between
two ladder trucks as the plane carrying
these men rolled in this moment when the
president and first lady holding hands
went up the stairs spending six minutes
in private conversation and then
unexpectedly because we didn't think
that was gonna happen unexpectedly
coming over with these men and taking a
number of questions from reporters who
had gathered around in front yelling
questions okay look at that look at that
photo op that's staged photo op how
terrible that photo op you mean like the
exact
photo-op that Barack Obama did in the
Rose Garden with Bowe Bergdahl's parents
to announce the return of a deserter in
exchange for terrorists you mean like
that photo op that the media didn't call
a photo op and if you'd said it was a
photo op no you were not allowed to say
was a photo it was bad to say that it
was a photo op because obviously listen
the President of the United States that
pointing who's well deserving with a
victory lap listen
are these all photo ops of course their
photo ops of course it's a photo op when
President Trump goes on the tarmac to
meet with people at 2:00 a.m. that's a
photo op okay if I were to meet somebody
at 2:00 a.m. the only reason I would do
that is for a photo op I'm not even sure
I would meet members of my family at
2:00 a.m. on a tarmac and it's really
early in the morning and you might sleep
but but for the media to critique this
by saying oh look at Trump he's a
reality show producer this is what's so
funny the media can't understand how a
reality TV guy became President of the
United States because she was the second
reality TV guy to become presidents of
the United States the first was Barack
Obama all of these photo ops all the
scripted nonsense existed for Barack
Obama to the media just refused to call
it out and then there's John Brennan
John Brennan's former CIA director under
Barack Obama and he says that Kim
jong-un is obviously Duke President
Trump how does he know that Kim jong-un
has do president Trump well he doesn't
but he was there when Barack Obama was
being duped by the Iranians he was there
when North Korea was duping Barack Obama
but but apparently he knows better he
knows now that Donald Trump was duped by
the North Koreans how does he know
because Donald Trump got to have a
photo-op and if he got a photo-op that
means that Trump must have given up
something awful in in exchange oh I
think he is very smartly and very
masterfully kim-jong escalated and saber
rattled so that he could then switch and
appear much more accommodating and
present a more peaceful face and so now
we've gone from mr. Trump calling him
Rocket Man and sick puppy to honorable
and nice okay well does it ever occur to
John Brennan that Donald Trump does that
as a as a fig leaf for his actual policy
Donald Trump says a lot of things and
then again you could put this on down
Trump's F to tap the dude said a lot of
stuff Donald Trump says a lot of things
but the question is what he actually
does and this is what the American
people are starting to recognize about
President Trump that despite and maybe
because of all the pyrotechnics because
of all the craziness it is sometimes
possible to ignore all of the good
things that are happening and you can
see that the folks
MSNBC don't understand this I do
appreciate the the silliness of the host
there refers to Kim Jeong RunAs hoon
that's not the way that Korean names
work his name is Kim right his last name
is Kim but in any case John Brennan you
know making the case that Donald Trump
is being duped by the North Koreans with
no evidence that he's actually being
duped by the North Koreans to this point
other than Donald Trump said something
on a tarmac about these people being
treated very nicely by Kim jong-un which
obviously was untrue Trump says a lot of
stuff right file that wonder Trump says
a lot of stuff but for a guy who's a
dupe he seems to be doing pretty
decently at this and at least he's
surrounding himself with people who are
certainly not being duped out speaking
of Democrats who say that Trump was
being duped Nancy Pelosi
she of the moving dentures she suggested
that President Trump had failed in his
oath to protect and defend the United
States by pulling out of the Iran deal
very very sad we take an oath to protect
and defend that is our first
responsibility I do not think the
president is honoring that oath by what
he did well okay so he's not honoring
his of what exactly is the oute that
he's not honoring you mean the oath to
uphold the Constitution which was a step
which was openly breached by pushing the
Iran ziyal the Iran's goal was not a
treaty the arange Hill is an executive
agreement between Barack Obama and the
Iranian government it was not approved
by the Senate in order for treaty to be
approved by the Senate you need at least
60 votes to approve that treaty in the
Senate did not get 60 votes in the
Senate and had a 21 percent approval
rating among the American public at the
time that it was passed when John Van
Horn's made a great point over a
commentary he said one of the reasons
that the Democrats were so attached to
the Iran deal is because they felt it
was a great triumph of them over the
public it was their ability to steamroll
everybody and push through a deal that
everyone thought was garbage that made
them celebrate it they thought it was in
in a real demonstration of their power
of their will of their ability to cram
down things the American people didn't
want on a stupid unwilling American
public but Donald Trump reached some
sort of constitutional duty by pulling
out of a deal with a terrorist nation
Donald Trump did that or is it Barack
Obama breaching his constitutional duty
to defend the United States by signing a
deal with it with a regime that has
killed American soldiers it has to be
clear about this during the a walk Iraq
war there are on/back militias they were
murdering American soldiers and wounding
American soldiers there's a lot of IEDs
set by Iranian troops produced in Iran
that were used MAME American troops
Barack Obama signed a deal with those
people and got nothing in return zero
things in return
but Donald Trump is the one who's a dupe
Donald Trump is the one who's a fool
there's a reason why the American people
are trusting Republicans more on foreign
policy these days than they trust
Democrats and part of that is because
the American people when it comes to
foreign policy they're not as as
sanguine about the possibilities of a
beautiful world as Democrats are
Democrats seem to always believe that if
we are just nice to everyone else
everyone else will be nice to us
that is not true you're nice to
everybody else until they are mean to
you at that point you clock them that's
an American foreign policy that I think
that the American people agree with
another demonstration of this obviously
is is the Democrats newfound opposition
to Jena Haspel Jena Haspel of course the
CIA nominee to be director first female
director in the history of the CIA and
Democrats are just fighting mad about
this how could Jena Haspel even be
considered considering that she worked
at the CIA at a time when the CIA was
engaged in waterboarding of terrorists
how could they possibly do all of this
now they were totally fine when John
Brennan was at CIA didn't matter John
Brennan worked at the CIA at the time
when waterboarding had been approved it
didn't matter that half the people at
the CIA worked at the CIA at the time
when waterboarding was used but now even
even the the remote idea that
waterboarding was a necessary evil that
was something that we had to do but it
did not constitute formal torture that
has been thrown out we can't know if you
say this it makes you a cruel inhumane
bad person now john mccain has said some
of these same things about waterboarding
but i have a little more sympathy for
john mccain saying i'm considering the
man was actually tortured in custody for
seven years i have a little more
sympathy hearing that from John McCain
who's tortured for no reason Rilla JIT
Amino reason other than to try and break
him I have more sympathy for that
position from McCain than I do from
Dianne Feinstein who knows better than
to assume the best about people like
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed one of the things
that is hilarious this week is Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed who is one of the
masterminds of 9/11 there are
suggestions that he was going to be
allowed to testify against Gina Haspel
and they were going to bring an actual
terrorist responsible for a 9/11 out of
jail so that he could talk about the
horrors he experienced at the hands of
Gina Haskell if you want to make Gina
Haspel President of the United States
that is the best way to do that
seriously bring bring a terrorist out
there to talk about Gina Haskell was
mean to him okay I would vote for her
for president
after hearing that because holy chick
Mohammed deserved every little bit of
everything that he got but beyond that
he also gave us a lot of actionable
intelligence because we waterboarded him
in just a second I'm going to show you a
clip of Dick Cheney Amman play for you a
clip of Dick Cheney talking specifically
about how Democrats really don't get it
right he explains why it is that
waterboarding was a necessary thing at
the time and again demonstrates why it
is that so many Americans are not going
to trust Democrats on foreign policy for
quite a while after Barack Obama but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at bull and branch so
here's the reality you're not sleeping
well but one of the reasons you're not
sleeping well is because you have a set
of crappy sheets right you just went to
your local retailer and you got a set of
sheets for like 50 bucks and you slap
them on there and it feels like you're
sleeping on plastic if you want the best
sheets that you can possibly sleep on
and a really affordable price go to bolt
and branch the bull and branch makes
everything from bedding to blankets and
it's made from pure 100% organic cotton
it starts out super soft to get softer
over time you buy directly from them so
you are essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to
thousand bucks in stores but you don't
have to spend that much money over a
bowl and branches a couple of hundred
bucks everyone who tries Boleyn branch
sheets love them actually we like them
so much that we legitimately took sheets
in our house and threw them out and
bought Poland branch sheets instead
because they are just that much more
comfortable it's it's very difficult to
sleep on non ball and branch sheets
after you've slept on ball and branch
sheets which is pretty much the only
downside shipping is free you can try
them for 30 nights and if you don't love
them you send them back for a refund I
doubt you're gonna want to send them
back they are that good to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch comp remote Club Ben
that's bull and branch comm promo code
Ben again go to bull and branch calm
promo club bent and you get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets the sheets are
just phenomenal you really really enjoy
them I promise
check them out bullet and branch comm
promo code Ben okay so speaking of
Democratic inability to understand the
heart of the American public the truth
is that in elections in the United
States from basically World War Two on
Republicans were trusted with security
far more than Democrats say after the
end of World War two and really with the
rise of President Eisenhower in the 1952
election since then Republicans have won
every foreign policy election and they
lost a lot of domestic elections so they
lost they won Eisenhower won on a
foreign policy Cold War I'm going to end
the war in Korea based election and then
Richard Nixon won on a wrestler
of security-based election we're going
to end the war in Vietnam with victory
and peace through victory right that was
going to be that was going to be the
idea from Richard Nixon and then end of
the Cold War Ronald Reagan ran on the
idea that the Soviet Union was an evil
empire and from 1980 to 1988 the
Republicans were present for 1988 to
1992 in the aftermath of that George HW
Bush was there to sort of do the cleanup
in the aftermath of the Cold War then he
got on some domestic issues right it was
the economy stupid that got Bill Clinton
into office in 1992 but as terrorism was
rising then George W Bush was trusted
more on foreign policy and then in the
2000 election and obviously he didn't
win the popular vote there but by 2004
clearly security was the top of the
agenda and he won reelection a
hard-fought reelection battle against
John Kerry by 2008 the American people
were ready to move on from national
security they didn't want to hear about
the Iraq war anymore they were tired of
the Iraq war they'd been convinced by
the media that the Iraq war was the
wrong thing to do because there weren't
massive stockpiles of new WMD found in
Iraq in the first place and so we had a
domestic policy election and Barack
Obama won on the basis of that hey but
the reality is that when it comes to
crises in foreign policy Republicans
aren't trusted more than Democrats
because Republicans are more realistic
than Democrats on all this stuff
they are they see the world as a dark
place filled with people who are trying
to kill us and we have to strengthen our
hand and this is why Dick Cheney for all
the talk about him being this evil Darth
Vader esque figure there are a lot of
folks in the United States who believe
well maybe you need Darth Vader if
you're staring down somebody even worse
well here here's Dick Cheney talking
about why the use of water borings or of
waterboarding during the war on terror
was a useful thing the techniques we
used were not tortured
a lot of people try to call it that but
it wasn't deemed torture at the time the
techniques we use our techniques were
use on our own people in training we
didn't go out and make them up someplace
president signed off I signed off and
have Security Council signed off they
did a good job they got the intelligence
they needed and we were safe from any
further mass casualty attacks on the
seven and a half years on our watch so
now people might have go back and try to
rewrite history but if it were my call
I'd do it again and most Americans I
believe still feel the same way despite
our sort of softness with regard to
waterboarding if there were another
terrorist attack in the United States of
9/11 scale the United States would
quickly shift into okay you do what you
need to get the information short of
actual full terror of full full torture
you know waterboarding is not full
torture we do use it to Train Navy SEALs
I watched as I say steven crowder get
waterboarded and dude is fine okay he's
just as crazy as you ever was but steven
crowder is totally fine it's not
somebody who's suffering from the
long-term after-effects of torture okay
well meanwhile the Muller probe it
continues to unfold and obviously
members of the Trump administration are
interested in wrapping this thing up is
this all a prelude to president from
firing Robert Miller I doubt it but I
think that they are trying to push
publicly for Muller and this probe and I
think that's appropriate because I think
that the molar probe does not appear to
have come up with anything so far in
terms of actionable intelligence about
the Trump administration a lot of the
late-breaking news about Michael Cohen
not about President Trump and short of
anything about President Trump and
Russian election collusion I don't see
the evidence at this point so here's
Mike Pence the vice president yesterday
saying listen it's time to wrap this
stuff this stuff up I mean we got enough
enough is enough about a year since this
investigation began our administration
has provided over a million documents we
fully cooperated in it and in the
interest of the country I think it's
time to wrap it up and I would very
respectfully encourage the special
counsel and his team to bring their work
to completion he was asked whether it
was witch-hunt he would he decline to
say that it was witch-hunt because he
doesn't want to look like he's stepping
on Muller completely but he's not wrong
when he says it's time to wrap this
thing up I mean the Muller investigation
has now been going on mount MOA was
appointed what May of last year so now
it's been going on for a full year the
Moller investigation and all of the talk
about Trump
collusion has been going on since the
middle of the 2016 election and nothing
right nothing the FBI has been looking
into this for two years and the best
they've been able to come up with his
George papadopolis low-level staffer met
with some Russian agents in London to
talk about leaks of Hillary emails and
went nowhere and then lied to the FBI
about it Papadopoulos which is why he is
probably gonna end up you know cutting
some sort of bargain all we've ended up
with is is a FISA warrant on Carter page
that resulted in no prosecution
whatsoever all we've ended up with is a
is a prosecution of Mike Flynn based on
him fibbing to the FBI about having a
conversation with the Russians after the
election having nothing to do with Trump
Russia collusion you know what any of
this stuff has to do with actual Trump
Russia election collusion is beyond me
and I think Trump is rightly angry about
this John Kelly the chief of staff for
president Trump he says that mostly the
president is just embarrassed and
annoyed by the investigation at this
point
is there a cloud because of it hanging
over this White House well yeah you know
it's there may not be a cloud but
certainly the president is somewhat
embarrassed frankly when world leaders
come in you know Bibi Netanyahu was here
and he was under investigation himself
and it's like you walk in and you know
the first couple of minutes of every
conversation might revolve around that
that kind of thing I mean you got to
sympathize with Trump to the extent that
Trump knows he didn't collude with
Russia and yet he's been hearing for two
years that he was he won an illegitimate
election because he colluded with Russia
that would annoy me too it would annoy
you - I think it would annoy everyone
you know this is all based on the
assumption he didn't actually collude
with Russia and I've seen no evidence
that he did at this point none has been
presented publicly so if mullahs got
something at a certain point you got to
say dude
wrap it up present your evidence let's
see what you got a show if you got
nothing then you got nothing now with
all of that said you know all of the
hubbub now surrounding Michael Cohen is
obviously not good for President Trump
the president has not surrounded himself
with the best people that is very clear
surrounding himself with Michael Cohen
was a foolish move from the very
beginning Michael Cohen is a dunderhead
that is obvious and the fact that
Michael Cohen continues to haunt the
president is largely a problem with
President Trump's own making in AT&T
announced today that they apologize for
ever having given money to Michael Cohen
they were apparently giving money to
Michael Cohen in the hopes that he would
essentially Lobby the President of the
United States on the AT&T Time Warner
merger they gave him about two hundred
thousand dollars the head of AT&T
legislative affairs office actually
resigned today
over all of this even though no illegal
activity took place they can give
Michael Cohen any amount of money they
want it's really up to Michael Cohen to
register as a lobbyist but it does make
it difficult for the president's in the
United States to claim that he's trying
to drain the swamp when all the people
around him are raking in the cash like
Michael Cohen under my administration
we're fighting against the lobbyists the
special interests and the corrupt
Washington politics after years of
rebuilding foreign countries of which a
lot of people are taking the costs of
rebuilding those foreign countries we
are finally rebuilding our country yes
when he says drain the swamp in these
rallies it's difficult to say that well
Michael Cohen is pulling down two
million dollars to be friends with
Donald Trump it makes things very
awkward it's why Donald Trump needs to
excise these people from his life it's
why the president needs to not engage us
now is he wrong that he's draining the
swamp as far as regulation no as far as
shrinking size of government regulation
I think that the president is doing his
best although he is signed into law a
couple of terrible omnibus packages and
he never should have signed into law the
real kind of draining the swamp has
little to do with firing Michael Cohen
as his attorney it has a lot more to do
with cutting the size and scope of
government I think that Trump in some
ways has his heart in the right place
there although he's not cutting the size
and scope of government I think nearly
enough to suit me but it does not help
his case when when Michael Cohen is
running around being Michael Cohen
okay now meanwhile the expertise of the
left is on full display and when it
comes to matters of genetics and reality
it's so bizarre yeah there are a lot of
folks on the left I spend my life going
to college campuses and being told that
I do not fully understand science that I
do not fully understand science I'm
going to explain in a second why it is
the left that apparently does not fully
understand science at least lately but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at American innovation so
American innovations of brand-new
podcast from wondering and it's awesome
okay I've listened to a few of their
first episodes and it really is good ok
the American innovations is hosted by
popular science author Steven Johnson
and they tell you stories behind a lot
of the science that you've heard of but
you don't know the backstory to so they
tell you the full story behind DNA and
the mapping of the human genome they
tell you the whole story the whole
backstory behind the rise of the
personal computer how it happened
artificial intelligence
all these things you become smarter just
by listening to this podcast it's not a
typical science podcast just a guy
talking into a mic about science you're
not only going to hear about the science
behind some of America's greatest
innovations you will actually be
immersed in the dramatic moments behind
the people place and time that led to
the amazing discoveries that we are all
living in that we all get to benefit
from in our lives the first six episodes
are actually written by New York Times
bestselling author Sam keen you can hear
the first three episodes right now by
searching for American innovations on
Apple podcast so this weekend when
you're not listen to my Sunday special
and when you're not catching up on ben
shapiro show right tomorrow is a
Saturday no new material tomorrow that
means it's time to listen to American
innovations on Apple podcast wherever
you're listening to this head over to
wonder EFM slash Ben that's wonder if m
/ Ben go search for American innovations
on Apple podcasts or wherever you're
listening right now or head over to
wonder eat FM / Ben this show is really
great it's really fascinating and you
learn a lot so check it out wonder EFM
slash Ben and then slash Ben lets them
know that we sent you alright so
speaking of science the left obviously
is having some trouble with the sign so
this comes up in a couple of different
contexts today context number one
apparently Donald Trump told John
McEnroe the the former number one seated
tennis player who's now he's got to be
pushing 16 John McEnroe but John McEnroe
was was apparently at some event and
Donald Trump passed a note up to him
offering to pay John McEnroe a million
dollars if you'd play a match with
Serena Williams here is John McEnroe
talking about it I was calling a match
and suddenly I get this envelope and
it's from Donald Trump you know whose
promoter Galore little did I know what
was gonna end up happening nor I believe
anyone else so he wrote me a letter said
you know Dear John you know I want to
offer you a 1 million dollars again to
play either Serena or Venus and so over
the course of time literally you know my
kids you know my daughters have dad I
don't know if you can beat Serena I'm
like God hey my kids on my side okay the
answer is he could probably beat Serena
okay but CNN's Christine Brennan says no
either Venus or Serena would have
pummeled John McEnroe the former number
one player in the world first of all I
hung out in their primes because I know
are you talking about when John McEnroe
is 60 still probably no
it's the truth but here here they're
talking about it on CNN and obviously
female power means that women have the
same musculature and capacity in sports
as men if you're stupid so here is
here's Christine Brennan trying to
explain can we talk about him saying
that he was sure that he would have
beaten Serena or Venus Williams I mean I
don't think he can be so sure
well he's in his late 50s Breanna and I
don't think anyone would want to see
that but I think Serena or Venus would
have pummeled him a la Billie Jean King
over Bobby Riggs back in 1973 ah okay
Billie Jean King beat Bobby Riggs
because Bobby Riggs threw the match okay
he legitimately threw the match and he
was a drunk old dude okay the idea that
that match is one of the great
annoyances for anyone who knows anything
about sports it is such an annoyance
when people say the Billie Jean King
beat beat Bobby Riggs straight up hey
Bobby Riggs threw the match before the
match
hey this is there's very little doubt
about this at this point and here is my
proof that John McEnroe would in fact
beat Serena Williams okay and certainly
in his prime would have beat Serena
Williams no question first of all Serena
Williams has said before she doesn't
play on the men's tour because she
wouldn't win on the men's tour this is
obviously true okay many years ago very
early in Venus and Serena's career in
1998 Serena Williams decided she thought
she could beat some men so she was in an
ATP Tour office at the Australian Open
and a guy named Carsten brash who you've
never heard of because he was an okay
player but he wasn't anything special
he's once a top 40 player at his best
but at this point when he met Serena
Williams in 1998 who's ranked 200 and
third in the world 200 and third in the
world so Serena was talking about how
she might be able to beat some of the
men he said okay one play match and so
both Serena and Venus showed up to play
rather than sit to play matches with him
right just for fun so brash this
according to USA Today the date was set
in the day arrived brash played a
warm-up round of golf in the morning
then came to Melbourne Park
the threesome went to the backcourt
where each sister would have a one set
shot at brash word had spread around the
grounds the event was taking place which
caused tournament officials to restrict
admittance to the area to only those
with badges brash smoked and sipped
beers during the change overs and to be
honest no longer looked the part of a
fit professional athlete brash led 500
verse arena before winning the set 6-1
and then posted a six to set victory
over Venus okay he was old he's wearing
203rd the world he's smoking and
drinking beer between the rounds and he
kicked the crap out of Serena and Venus
Williams that is not a rip on Serena and
Venus Williams as athletes they are
incredible athletes there are also women
and to pretend that women and men are
exactly the same when it comes to
physical capacity is just idiotic it's
just stupid okay she is the greatest
female tennis player of all time
but her fastest recorded serve was 129
miles per hour okay the fastest recorded
men's serve is 163 miles per hour in the
2015 Grand Slam Serena's average served
traveled 109 miles per hour Novak
Djokovic averaged 117 Andy Murray
averaged 114 so the experts have come up
with something called the universal
tennis rating okay it rates all players
on a single scale Djokovic there's a
couple years ago ranked at 16 point
three nine that was the highest in the
world Serena ranked at 13 point three
six which doesn't sound terrible until
you realize that that is the same
ranking as a mid ranked male college
tennis player okay so men and women they
don't have the same capacity okay this
is true when it comes to throwing
baseballs as well women on average
cannot throw as fast as men there are
some women who can throw pretty fast
there are no women who can throw 95
miles per hour
okay the average woman throws a baseball
slower then this is real statistic
that's not me making it up the average
woman throws a baseball slower then out
of 1,000 men 998 of those men okay the
average woman throws faster than two out
of 1,000 men that you pick up the street
so let's get over this whole women and
men are exact insane they're not exactly
the same again does this make women
worse no does it make women worse at
sports yes by any objective measure but
why is this even chap but ah feminists
don't you understand you undermined your
case when you suggest that men and women
are exactly the same or they should be
treated exactly the same don't you
understand that it's really stupid
because then you know what happens
Fallon Fox who is a dude who is
transgender fights women in you in MMA
and beats the living crap out of them
because he still has male musculature
and it's unfair because a man beating
the hell out of women this whole thing
is so stupid speaking of expertise on
the Left I have to play this clip
because it's just incredible so there's
an expert in Britain I love what what
now passes for being an expert it's
pretty spectacular this is an
spurt in Britain trying to explain that
parents should ask babies for permission
to change their diapers is a sexuality
expert an author named Deanne Carson and
she was speaking to ABC News in
Australia and she was asked what age
clients she work so she said we work
with children from 3 years old we work
with parents from birth and then Carson
explains exactly what she means by that
we work from children from 3 years old
we work with parents from birth from
birth yeah yep just about how to set up
a culture of consent in their home so
I'm going to change your nappy now is
that ok
of course the baby's not going to
respond yes ma'am that's awesome I'd
love to have my nappy changed but if you
leave a space and wait for body language
and wait to make eye contact then you're
letting that child know that their
response matters um no ok there's a
parent to his appearance of a four year
old and two year old one of whom is out
of diapers and the other one who will
soon be out of diapers I hope okay
here's the truth
if you leave your kids to decide when
they want their diapers change they will
have diaper rash forever forever okay if
I let my two-year-old son explain to me
when he wants to stay first of all he's
really smart so he actually does like
hehehe as soon as he goes to the
bathroom
he immediately tells us like right then
he says okay peepee poo-poo whatever and
then we go and change him but my
daughter was not so much like that right
she she when she was very young shoot
she was also clean freak and so and
she's a little baby she would not eat
until she'd been change but as she got
older because kids do this she started
getting angry when you would change her
diaper and my son is starting get to
that age now to where he gets mad when
you change his diaper doesn't want a
sniper change he thrashes around on the
changing table you know you have to do
force your kids to change their diaper
if you're not an idiot but apparently
being an idiot is an actual
qualification for being an expert on
parenting on national TV no listen I
don't want to I don't want a stereotype
this woman Deanne Carson I don't know if
she has kids I don't know who does her
hair but this is dumb okay this is
incredibly dumb and it's amazing what
constitutes expertise now that the
parenting experts know so little about
what actually happens with regard to
parent with regard to parenting so many
of them are basing it off of bad social
science or based on you know these tiny
uncontrolled studies that
in that a lot of what they have to say
is just absolutely counterintuitive and
then they claim that they are experts in
science first and these religious
parents who do things like change their
kids diapers without their kids
permission you're violating consent
you're part of rape culture if you
change your kids diapers or some such
nonsense okay
so I'm gonna get to the mailbag in just
a second first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at the u.s. CCA so
this one is for my pro-second amendment
listeners out there which is virtually
all of you I believe so I've gotten a
great opportunity for you to win an
expensive new gun but you have to be
law-abiding and also you have to ask act
fast so the u.s. ECA is giving you five
chances to win $1,000 to buy an
expensive new Kimber micro with extra
ammo as a strong supporter of the Second
Amendment I'm also a proud member of the
US ECA because they have all sorts of
fantastic services including educational
services informational services legal
services and they love giving away free
guns to law-abiding citizens so you can
protect yourself go to defend my family
now.com and walk in your 5 free chances
to win right now defend my family now
calm and lock in those 5 free chances to
win don't miss out on that chance to win
a thousand bucks for your very own
Kimber it is defiant one of the finest
handguns out there but it all ends the
25th so you have to hurry go to defend
my family now calm right now for those 5
chances to win it's 100% free you can
enter in seconds and it gives you those
5 opportunities yeah again you're a
law-abiding citizen if you don't own a
gun you probably should for self defense
and for various other reasons I think
that it's worthwhile owning weaponry and
defend my family now.com go register you
could actually win one at the very least
you'll be registering with the US CCI
which is a great organization to begin
with go check it out now defend my
family now dot-com alrighty so we are
now going to get to the mailbag but
first you're going to have to go over to
daily wire calm now the reason you're
gonna want to is because if you want to
ask me questions that's the only way to
do it okay you think that you're sending
me these emails and I'm gonna answer all
of them I get hundreds of emails a day I
mean not to be self-centered but I'm a
popular fellow I get lots and lots of
emails how do you know that your
question is actually going to be
answered you know it's gonna be answered
when you actually send it to me via
Daily wire and the way you do this is
you go to our daily wired chatroom right
now as I'm about to do the mailbag after
you subscribe and then you can ask me
questions live and I will answer them
for you on air plus you can ask
questions of our other hosts including
the execrable michael knowles it's
almost time for our next episode of the
conversations Tuesday May 15 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
Michael Mills will be here to answer
your questions which means that he will
stare blankly into camera and then make
an obscure reference
to a Catholic theologian you've never
heard of Michael the moles will answer
all of those questions if you go over to
daily wire.com and you subscribe all you
have to do to subscribe go over and
subscribe and then everybody can watch
this right at YouTube Facebook you can
watch all of it live
Alicia Kraus will be there and she will
be reading all of your questions to him
live for a full hour and you will get
all of your questions answered
even if badly by Michael moles so go
check that out plus you should subscribe
also because it helps us bring you the
show okay let's be honest about this it
is your subscriptions that allow us to
bring you the show and allow us to bring
you the Sunday specials our new Sunday
special is going it's coming up on
Sunday because it's Sunday special if
you can get that from the name and we
are featuring Dave Rubin so Dave Rubin
stops by for the full hour as Larry King
might say and it is excellent it's a
really a lot of fun to listen to you've
seen a lot of hubbub about the about the
intellectual dark web this week well
Dave is a charter member and a connector
within the intellectual dark web
and we'll have full discussions about
Dave's philosophy and the stuff that
Dave has to say well in here's a little
bit of what it sounded like when I sat
down with Dave Rubin but one of the
great things about Dave Rubin is that
the first time I was introduced to I
think was probably on your show we knew
each other before before I was on your
show and you are I think one of the best
interviewers in the business so people
normally see stuff like this and expect
us to see the chairs reversed yeah
remember what's what's really fun about
this I actually want to ask about some
of the setting your own journey because
you don't actually get to talk about
that too much
very quickly though I just for the
record clearly by you being an interview
that you stole this from me I was the
one that came up with the idea of the
interview know much people sitting there
talking about you have culturally
appropriated it for me I just want to
put oh yeah and then just like just like
America we've been culturally
appropriated from others and then we're
gonna make the best of it make more
money so that I mean that's that's our
actual plan it should be really really
good so you're gonna want to check it
out
so go over our Sunday special that's why
you should subscribe go over to iTunes
leave us a review subscribe if you want
the annual subscription then get the
annual subscription which comes along
with this the very greatest in leftist
tears hot or cold vessels it is just
fantastic
that's $99 a year your annual is better
than your monthly check it all out over
at daily wire com we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty it is time to mailbag it up
so let's do this thing so Jim says hello
Ben as a father of three beautiful girls
I feel it behooves me to make the world
a better place for them I personally
think our national debt needs to be
reconciled above all else and that
entails entitlement reform no politician
wants to discuss what do you think is
the number-one threat the next
generation faces and how can we fix it
today I think in terms of government
that's exactly right I mean in terms of
government the the blowing out of the
national debt and the creation of an a
fiscally irresponsible deficit that's
gonna be paid off by our kids and our
kids kids he's really awful and it's one
of the things that Paul Ryan was trying
to push it's one of the shortcomings of
President Trump who really doesn't care
too much about entitlement reform he
thinks it's politically toxic he may be
right that it's politically toxic but
you got to do it anyway because if you
actually want to save the country you
can't be waiting until 20 years from now
when Social Security goes fully bankrupt
not even 20 years probably 10 15 years
from now when it goes fully bankrupt and
you're looking at drastically raising
taxes or continuing to blow out our
national debt which essentially
outsources our foreign policy to people
who own our debt puts us in severe
fiscal need so that stuff Republicans
ought to be pursuing right now and they
ought to be making strong moral
arguments for why Social Security needs
to be restructured I think young people
in particular are willing to hear that
argument and if they care about Social
Security they're willing to hear it you
don't want you don't want your taxes
raised and you want more money back from
the government you can have both of
these things all we have to do is make
Social Security a private thing as
opposed to making it a public thing okay
Noah says hi Ben I'm a new daily wire
subscriber I was wondering what you
would say president Trump's greatest
accomplishment as president is at this
time he has a bunch of accomplishments
that I think are really great I think
the tax cuts are excellent I think that
his stacking of the courts is probably
the single best thing the his stacking
of the courts with with conservatives
who are going to be on those courts for
decades is is an excellent excellent
necessary thing because otherwise the
judiciary just becomes a tool of the
left beyond that obviously the movement
of the embassy to Jerusalem pulling out
of the Iran deal all of that is terrific
cutting down on regulation the man's got
a lot of accomplishments I mean I can't
be unhappy with his policy so far I
think is policy so far has been terrific
as I've said to top members of the
administration you know a - on executive
policy C+ on legislative policy dd2 F on
rhetoric I think his rhetoric has
improved of late you know he hasn't had
any big charlottesville boo-boos as he
as he used to
hopefully that lasts but you know it's
it's a day ending in
so there'll be a tweet storm coming soon
Susan says question hey man you clearly
have amazing recall I imagine much of
that as IQ but any tips for the lay
person of the world to help us keep our
memories sharp well when it comes to you
know actively attempting to memorize now
I'm lucky because I have a pretty good
memory for things I want to I want to
think about but what I do find helps is
writing stuff down so not even looking
back at what you've written down but the
very act of writing things down is very
helpful it's a good study method for
kids who are in school if you're in high
school you're in junior high you're
trying to study for a test
write things and write them by hand not
type okay typing it doesn't get in your
head quite as much grab a pen write down
the stuff you want to remember the very
act of writing almost engraved in on
your memory so I would I would highly
recommend that as a memory tool also you
then have notes that you can later use I
make a mistake I think when I read books
and I've had this discussion with a with
a couple of people in in recent
interviews Jordan Peterson most
specifically I think talked about
highlighting books I believe is Jordan I
am NOT somebody who highlights my books
because I have a lot of reverence for
for the written word and for books and I
don't like to facing my books but I was
hearing from it wasn't Jordan was
somebody else it's gonna annoy me now
but so my memory had that great but the
but if he but what he was saying is that
it was Glenn Beck was Glenn so Glenn was
saying that he enjoyed highlighting
books specifically because he would take
notes on in the margins of books and
then his kids are always fascinated by
his thought process as he was reading
which i think is actually kind of a cool
thing so writing in books writing this
stuff down is probably the best way to
approach that John says hi Ben hello
Obama can't work now that the tax cuts
and Jobs Act repealed its funding
mechanism in the individual mandate
since it is a mandatory expenditure
wouldn't other tax dollars now have to
be allocated to it or will it just cease
to exist
thanks love the show this is the big
question after he got rid of the
individual mandate which was the funding
mechanism to pay for all the increased
costs and regulation of Obama care the
only way that you're going to be able to
bring costs down in the individual
marketplace is by getting rid of
regulation or by subsidizing the federal
government has chosen to subsidize which
is why I'm not in love with just getting
rid of the individual mandate alone
that's good but you're gonna have to do
more than that otherwise you're gonna be
blamed for an increase in the price of
individual health care plans so this is
why getting rid of regulation is what
was deeply necessary and unfortunately
did not happen that's a major
shortcoming of Republican Congress and
it behooves us to remember that Chris
has been can you explain the central
banking system the purpose
Federal Reserve the positive and
negative sides alike please so the
Federal Reserve was originally
established in in the beginning of the
depression basically and it was
established in order to say to banks
that if you lose all of your money
we can provide you a certain percentage
of your money back to you so this is why
the FDIC the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation ensures that the first I
believe two hundred thousand dollars of
money that you have in the bank you will
get back regardless of whether the bank
goes bust this is the federal government
saying it's try and prevent runs on bank
the way it used to work is that if there
is a bank it had a certain amount
wandering in the bank the bank never has
as much money in the bank as it owes to
people right because when you give money
to the bank the bank doesn't just keep
it in the back room the bank lends that
out to people at interest that's how the
bank makes its money well what happens
if everybody who has their money stored
in the bank goes and asked for their
money at the same time the bank doesn't
have that money it goes bankrupt and it
starts trying to call in loans right
this is what happen at the beginning of
the Great Depression everybody started
to have everybody started going to the
bank and withdrawing the money from the
bank so the solution by the federal
government was the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation which was run by
the Fed and the idea there was that they
were going to be able to insure your
losses by banks now the problem with
this is it does create a significant
amount of moral hazard moral hazard
being that banks can now be
loosey-goosey about the amounts of money
that they lend out knowing the federal
government is gonna back their play at
the end or bail them out in the end and
that this has been the problem with the
Fed from beginning is the possibility of
moral hazard where people act
irresponsibly and then the federal
government bails them out as we saw
actually in 2008-2009 the Fed has some
other stuff that it does in conjunction
with the Department of the Treasury the
Department of the Treasury sells bonds
stocks and bonds and the Federal Reserve
works with the government the Department
of the Treasury in order to provide the
the dollars that are used in the sales
of stocks and bonds when the government
buys back bonds for example they're
trying to take more bonds out of the
market they're trying to inflate the
currency or the amount of currency
that's in circulation Milton Friedman
was a big fan of the Fed actually he
thought that the the Fed should should
set a standard growth rate in the amount
of money in circulation on a particular
year by your basis is like 2% now then
there are people who are Chicago school
so Chicago school economists sit and
think the Fed auto exists that the Fed
ought to have control over the amount of
money in circulation and then there's
the Vienna School of Economics which
suggests that we really should be on a
gold standard
and the government shouldn't be able to
manipulate the amounts of currency
that's in circulation that happens
through a sort of complex process
between the Fed and the Department of
the Treasury I tend to be on the Vienna
School of Economics I'd I'm not a big
fan of the Federal Reserve I think the
Federal Reserve it creates a sense of
security that I think is unwarranted and
that leads again companies to rely on
the federal government to bail them out
and now bailouts are enshrined in the in
the dodd-frank Act and that really needs
to be gutted as well I mean that's
something else that the Republicans
ought to be pursuing right now as well
okay let's see Harrison says hey but I
was wondering what your opinion is of a
negative income tax such as the one
proposed by Milton Friedman as an
alternative to the welfare state so as
an alternative to the welfare state I'm
for it as an adjunct to the welfare
state I'm against it so the negative
income tax is that idea that based on
your income we sign one we basically
guarantee you a minimum income it's
basically an a universal basic income
but he says that you should have a
negative income tax based on the amount
of money that you make and we will sign
a check to you back from the federal
government for a particular amount of
money but it's not going to be dependent
on the amount of money that you make
completely and it's also not going to
require that you be single for example
that you're a single mother and it's not
going to be welfare state based it's
going to be it's going to be a certain
sliding scale that we give you of a
consistent amount of money that goes
into your bank accounts and that is what
it is and as it would be a lot cheaper
than a welfare state no question you
wouldn't need the infrastructure of the
welfare state so I agree that as it is a
there's alternative to the welfare state
would be great I tend to oppose both of
them because I don't think that's a
useful thing and rely instead on private
charity Thomas says hi Ben in regard to
the more progressive in regards to
progressivism plaguing the nation do you
see America ever returning to its more
conservative judeo-christian roots and
what would it take to get us there I
think that what it would take to get us
there is to recognize that our moral
roots our judeo-christian whether you
like it or not this is an argument that
I've been having repeatedly with a lot
of folks who are Enlightenment thinkers
Neal Enlightenment thinkers I've had
this argument now with Sam Harris and
and with not really the Jonah Goldberg
openly but I would certainly like to
discuss it with John I think he'd
probably agree with me actually and and
I had this argument with Michael Shermer
there are a lot of people who are so
I've had the segment about Steven Pinker
enlightenment thinking is rooted in
judeo-christian values you want to get
people back to judeo-christian values
what you say is listen all the stuff
that's around you that was built by
judeo-christian civilizations and
behoove you to study the foundational
documents of the judeo-christian vision
and then to see how those documents have
been interpreted over the last several
thousand years to bring us here because
there's this myth that's going around
that what happened is that in the 18th
century late 18th century early 19th
century there's a vast shift in public
thinking and the thinking went we reject
the Bible and from that came everything
grand that is a lie it is not
historically true it is not
philosophically true it is not morally
true and I think that we needed to bunk
that if we are actually going to fight
for judeo-christian values ok Derek says
salutations Ben I want to ask why does
the left hate Western culture almost
everything great about the modern world
is due to the progress of Western
civilization yet the left loathes the
very foundations that made such an
incredible world it's mind-boggling
sincerely Derek well I think that what
the left sees when they see Western
civilization is inequality so the reason
the Left hates Western civilization is
because the left says as Mark said that
individual human beings are created by
the system in which we live we don't
have free will in the sense that we can
really move beyond the system what we
have to do is tear down the system we
have to tear it out at its roots and
then we can build a better more utopian
world and from that utopian world will
come at transcendental man welcome a new
type of human being was kinder and and
more generous and better to other human
beings but that can only change if you
get rid of the system itself and so what
the left tends to focus on is all of the
shortcomings of the system so what are
the shortcomings of the system in the
freest most prosperous time in human
history
well the shortcomings of the system our
lack of soul so in throughout the 20th
century the left kept saying that even
during the 1950s when everybody was
booming and it seemed like America was
finally starting to move beyond its
racial problem I mean the civil rights
memorial starts in the 50s not the 60s
and there's real change coming in
America all of it good or at least a
large part of it good feminism is the
early first stage feminism is beginning
and all that is good you know with the
left says no the reason there are sexism
the reason there is racism the reason
there's brutality is because of this
capitalist system and all these people
who you see who are engaged in the
capitalist system are truly empty Souls
these are people who have nothing to
live for
they're just shells of their former self
they're missing meaning and that missing
meaning is is a generation of Western
civilization it was generated by Western
civilization so all we have to do is get
rid of all of these Western civilized
notions about free freedom individual
rights
we have to get rid of this whole shtick
about capitalism and when we do that we
will have a better human being in a
better world so that's that's the reason
they're trying to propose a utopian
vision to replace the Western civilized
vision failing to recognize of course
that all the good stuff around them is
inextricably intertwined with the
principles that generated it in the
first place
Fernando says I got asked this question
during dinner with a couple of friends
what is the soul I did not know how to
answer what do you believe in is the
definition of uh soul so this is a hard
question because obviously the soul is
improvable it's not verifiable there's
no real way to tell what a soul is so
there are various definitions of the
soul so Thomas Aquinas has an
interesting definition of the soul he
says that basically things are people
are made up of form and matter right so
you are made up of matter and you are
made up of form so the form precedes the
matter in sort of platonic and in the
Platonic narrative that there is a form
of a dog that God has in mind and then
there is a dog right that there is there
is the form of dog and the reason that
you know all dogs are similar is because
there's a Platonic idea of dog right and
then so all those dogs fall under that
one Platonic ideal of the dog the same
thing holds true with regard to form and
matter sort of according to Aquinas so
the idea there is that you there is a
form of you right there's a form of man
and that encompasses what you are and
that survives death but it is more that
it is more than your constituent parts
in other words and that's what the soul
is so the form is the soul so whether
that survives death or not the idea is
that the form is you and it's not just
your constituent parts I think there's
something to that
I also think that there's a good case to
be made that the soul is the is what
animates you that when you die the soul
obviously leaves your body and what we
mean by that is that the animating force
that allows you to live and think and
make decisions freely has now left you
and so that that's what I think the soul
is what the soul does after death is
beyond me I don't know the answer no one
knows the answer because it's your
question you believe Jesus came back to
tell everybody there are very few people
who have come back to tell anybody about
what happens after death I have my own
theories as to what happens after death
but those theories actually we'll be
discussing that I think in a coming
Sunday special sometime pretty soon okay
one more of these okay one more Natalie
says that I'm currently an intern at a
big corporate law firm I'm starting law
school next year while the work of an
attorney interest in excites me I'm
concerned growing concerned about
balancing the demands corporate law and
family
I look around at this law firm and see a
lot of very successful females but most
of them especially partners and
high-level associates are not married
and do not have kids since more than
anything else I want to get married and
have children in the future
Michelle Obama thinks you're a terrible
person do you think it is possible for a
female to be both a good corporate
attorney and a good wife and mother at
the same time Thanks
so I think the answer is it is certainly
possible to be a good corporate attorney
and a good wife and mother I do think
that there are trade-offs and to pretend
that there are no trade-offs is to
ignore reality hours that you spend at
work are hours that you're not spending
at home and hours that you spend at home
are not hours that you are spending at
work and I do not think that a good
corporate law job substitutes for having
a happy home life I think almost nothing
substitutes for having a happy home life
you know and I'm feeding someone whose
wife works extraordinarily long hours
right my wife works really long hours
like today she took off from the house
at 7:45 she'll be back tonight at 6:30
that is a normal day for her that is a
good rotation for her her prior rotation
she was going in at 5:00 a.m. and she
was coming back at 10:00 P some days
okay that is hard and it's hard on the
family it's hard on the kids we've made
provision for that right I'm home a lot
more than she is
my parents are over a lot we have a
nanny right all of these things are
great but is it a trade-off of course
it's a trade-off and it's a trade-off
that she struggles with and she feels
every day I think one of the great lies
that feminism has told to women is you
can have it all you can have a lot of
good things but to pretend that there
are no trade-offs among those things I
is to is to be foolish I just don't
think that that's true in any real sense
okay time for a thing I hate and then
some thing I like and then some things
that I hate so the thing I like there's
a movie that's now available on Amazon
Prime it's called last flag flying it's
really good for the acting you know it's
it's very anti-war obviously because
every movie that Hollywood has ever
produced since the Vietnam War has been
an anti-war movie basically there are a
couple of exceptions like 12 strong is
an exception but this movie the acting
is really first-rate it's Bryan Cranston
and Laurence Fishburne and Steve Carell
Cranston is of course the the highlight
of the show he really is terrific in
this film but Laurence Fishburne turns
and really the performance as well these
are basically the stories these three
guys were in the Army together in
Vietnam back during the Vietnam War and
now Steve Carell son was in the Marines
his son was killed and these and he
tries to go get these two guys to come
with him to pick up his son's body and
bring it to Arlington but it turns out
that the Army has lied to him about how
his son died and now he doesn't want to
bury his son in Arlington and said he
wants to bury his son back home here's a
little bit of the preview
you know what amazes me about you what
could be anything I'm a pretty amazing
guy
you turn the keys of your bar over the
guy who's asleep on your pool table and
then you jump in your car and you drive
me to hell and gone and you don't even
know where we're going ask the question
willing to surrender to God what the
hell happened to Mueller the Mahler
first-class drinker gamblers some
visitors amongst us here today we were
in the service together with your pastor
I haven't seen these minute decades they
represent a dog period in my life that
went down on all the quick drinking
Fortuna
you got old and boring shine down
because I'm not a huge Richard Linklater
fan as a general rule but the movie is
actually quite good and the acting more
than anything else it really is a
showcase for the three performers
involved so if you like good acting and
the script is is entertaining even if
it's anti-war it's really anti rock war
and there are a couple of lines the
Assumption in Hollywood always is that
the Iraq war was a terrible terrible
awful horrible terrible terrible mistake
and so everything they ever say about
the Iraq war is based on that argument
which i think is a deeply flawed
argument but it is still worth the watch
if if you're just looking for some solid
performances okay time for some things
that I hate all right so I have to show
you this clip from April Ryan April Ryan
is of course the White House
correspondent I can never remember which
outlet she is which is for but she's a
White House reporter she was on CNN last
night and she was discussing Melania
Trump and she's four American urban
radio networks and here's what April
Ryan had to say about Melania Trump it's
just an amazing thing where she's
allowed to get away with this so John
Kelly the White House chief of staff is
being accused of racism today because he
suggested that a lot of illegal
immigrants who come to the United States
are undereducated which is technically
true okay that is just a fact a lot of
illegal immigrants who come to the
United States are undereducated but
April Ryan is not considered in any ways
you know phobic for saying this about
Melania Trump she wants to just show
young people how it's done and do it
right and they will pick up those those
habits I wonder if the president will
change but but there are realities there
are a lot of realities that she's
dealing with this is this is a first
lady who is not culturally American but
she is learning the ways I don't even
know what that means
the Melania Trump is not culturally
American what exactly does that mean she
has a foreign accent
and what about Melania Trump is not
culturally American she seems pretty
culturally American to me yeah again
this it's amazing if somebody were to
say that on the write about anybody on
the left with an accent
that'll be oh my god racism xenophobia
terrible how could you what about that
person is bad my in-laws are culturally
American they have very strong Israeli
accents they're culturally American
they've been living in America since my
wife was 12 years old which means that
they've been here I'm not gonna give
away my wife's age but they've been her
for a little while okay
my wife wouldn't care
if so she's been there for 18 years no
that's 30 she doesn't care where was but
it's but the but the truth is that April
Ryan's allowed to get away with this
because April Ryan obviously is a member
of minority group if you're a member of
minority group then you can say anything
about any other member of minority group
my proof being that the members of the
women's March are members of minority
groups can hang out with freakin Lewis
Farrakhan and everybody just goes oh
well whatever who cares right keith
Ellison can be an actual anti-semite and
he's being quoted in the media today
saying I'm very upset that people are
calling me an anti-semite I think that
it's awful they're calling me an
anti-semite I'm more upset that you are
an anti-semite dude but you're allowed
to get away with it because if you have
the right skin color apparently you're
allowed to be a racist which is really
awful awful awful stuff okay other
things that I hate so George
Stephanopoulos just doing yeoman's work
on behalf of NBC and George
Stephanopoulos does have a long history
of defending people who are accused of
sexual misconduct going all the way back
to the Clinton days Tom Brokaw has been
accused of sexual harassment by Lynde
investor who was a former reporter at
NBC News and or at ABC News rather and
this is pretty funny because George
Stephanopoulos rushes to Tom Brokaw's
defense table broke was pretty angry he
says he was ambushed
says he was perp-walked what's your
response well I expected a denial that
is what harassers generally do what I
didn't expect was such a personal attack
and what I'm concerned about is the
message that that sends to women inside
NBC News about whether or not they are
safe to report somebody who is powerful
if they get that kind of backlash in
that letter he describes you as a
colleague who has trouble with the truth
are you absolutely convinced that
everything you remember about that it's
in at those incidents with Tom Brokaw
what happened George my memory of those
incidents is crystal clear the notes
that I took immediately afterward are
crystal clear there's a Lin investor
from NBC News that obviously George
Stephanopoulos from ABC News imagined
him would he ask those questions at
stormy Daniels right really stormy
Daniels is an actual porn star right who
shall we say has some problems in her
life I would I think it's fair to say
store McDaniel as a person with some
problems in her life with George
Stephanopoulos sit there and ask do you
know Donald Trump had said that you're
lying do you truly recall what happened
are you sure you recall every minute of
what happened we said you know he's very
upset Donald he's very very upset with
you you know he's pretty angry are you
absolutely convinced that what you're
saying is true like come on come on I
know that NBC News investigated itself
and cleared itself but um you don't get
to investigate and clear yourself well
and then bring out a bunch of women who
are not Linda Bester in order to talk
about how Tom Brokaw was wonderful the
woman amazing how the media will circle
the wagons and from the me to movements
actually as soon as it's a member of
their own who's really under the gun
somebody who is is considered an iconic
figure in them in the media already so
we will be back here next week have
yourself a wonderful weekend don't try
to spoil things too much I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
mic Carmina hair and makeup is by Joshua
Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright floor publishing 2018